what is this okay so i'm supposed to be
doing an unboxing of the new hp omen
this is not a box i mean it is a box how
am i gonna get this out of here okay i
can't even move this i can't believe
that they froze a computer in a block of
ice this is fantastic this might be the
coolest unboxing
that i've ever done
all puns intended
congrats on receiving your metaphor now
get to melting okay so first of all a
huge thank you to hp for sponsoring this
video they were like justine we'd love
for you to review our new hp omen 45
leader with new cryo cooling and i was
like cool great love it and when they
told me the delivery was happening this
morning this is not what i expected so i
guess we need to get the computer out
before we unbox
set it up to do the review
okay
i've got tools for this ice pick
okay well i don't i don't want to be
here all day i need to do the review
see what else i've got
oh my goodness
what
i'm so happy
this is incredible
[Music]
i gotta take a break my finger hurts
from
flaming well that was fun but it's still
frozen
this is a little gift that i just got
it's a little tiny
chainsaw
[Music]
i need some safety glasses
look at that
okay so now i see how like ice sculpting
can be
really fun like this is oh my god do i
have a new hobby i don't have time for
new hobbies
[Music]
look at that
oh yeah we're making progress now
[Music]
no we're not i think i need a bigger
chainsaw like let's be real like this if
i want to start getting into carving and
making beautiful art this is great but
this is not
gonna get the job done
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
getting so close to the box
[Music]
oh we hit box we hit box we hit box
oh man i mean we're so close i'm gonna
just get this whole chunk off right here
jesus those things are happening
[Music]
oh
look at that
i need like a
shield
oh man
i got an idea
save that
for a nice drink later
[Music]
oh that did nothing
that did nothing
oh that did something
[Music]
[Applause]
did you see those quick feet
i'm gonna get my gloves
i got it i got it we're good we're good
we're good everyone everyone everyone
everything's fine everything's fine
okay well the ice is removed i think i
can just lift this out of here
oh
there's a mini ice skating rink for ants
i have plenty
[Music]
[Applause]
so as you can see i have everything all
set up that was probably one of the most
fun unboxings that i've ever done i
actually had to change my clothes
because everything was completely
soaking wet from the ice that had melted
so now that we're here it's all set up i
have a bunch of games installed and with
this new cryo chamber this is allowing
this new hp omen 45 liter desktop to be
one of the most cooling efficient
machines that hp has ever made so the
first thing that you're going to notice
is this pc definitely has a very
different look and that's because they
have the new cryo chamber up on top here
and that's going to be giving you so
much more space inside of the chassis
where normally you would have the entire
cooling system but they've done a really
great job of kind of integrating it into
the top and kind of making it look like
a piece of art not only looks cool but
it's actually efficiently cooling this
entire pc as you use it and this is
really exciting especially for people
who are doing a lot of processor
intensive things maybe you're a big
gamer or you're doing video editing or
you're doing 3d rendering whatever it is
if it is something that is processor
intensive you obviously do want a
machine that is efficiently being cooled
thus giving you better performance and
as someone who has overclocked their pcs
in the past this cryo chamber is
enabling the best overclocking with
their pre-built systems the omen 45l is
powered by the 12th gen intel core i9
processor with a new hybrid architecture
that matches the right core for the
right workload so background tasks won't
interrupt anything that you're actually
doing on your computer at that time
whether it's playing video games or
exporting a video this will be able to
make sure that you're running at peak
performance at all times another thing
that you'll notice is because the cryo
chamber is housing a lot of the cooling
properties the inside chassis of this
leaves you so much more space for
customizing and upgrading so as you can
see this cable management is also pretty
impressive all i know is if i was in
charge of this cable management it would
look like my office and that's not a
good thing so the 45l has maximum
thermals for maximum performance and
this can fit up to an nvidia 30 90. it
has 120 watt intel cpu you can install
up to 64 gigs of ram and up to 2
terabyte pci nvme ssds with direct
storage it supports intel cryo
technology it's got plenty of
overclocking headroom and capabilities
obviously it has incredible rgb lights
which is one of the things that i'm a
huge fan of and they're also
customizable this is cool because i can
actually see my monitor and my desktop
and this will allow me to customize all
of the colors and how i want the lights
to perform if i interact with each piece
it'll change the colors and how they
react
to
various situations you could definitely
play with this for hours there are
honestly endless patterns and colors and
combinations that you can make but i
think i'm just going to keep it a static
pink for the rest of this video you can
tell on the bottom that they have some
higher feet which this will help out
with some more air intake so they
clearly are taking all things cooling
into consideration it also has this
really nice removable dust filter right
here on the front and that's super easy
to get access to i love that you're able
to access the internals from both sides
of the machine so there is a little
button over here on the back that will
give you access to the back side of it
and this little glass front piece is
also accessible from the front i love
that they really took into consideration
that people nowadays like we're not just
buying these pre-built computers and
leaving them it's so easy to do
solid-state upgrades and ram upgrades so
basically buying a really nice pre-built
machine especially something like this
with so much room for upgrades is kind
of the way to go now obviously yes
building from scratch is pretty fun but
for most people i feel like this is the
perfect solution so i was also talking
about the customizable leds and this is
really cool so in the omen gaming hub
this gives you access to not only a
bunch of games but also their light
studio and this is actually even an hp
omen monitor that i was borrowing from
my sister because
she has done a bunch of videos with hp
in the past and i was like hey you have
that hp omen monitor can i please borrow
it so she brought this over and this
also has customizable lights as well
also in the omen gaming hub you can
check out all of the system vitals you
can see your gpu cpu and you can see how
much ram you're using could also adjust
your settings so if you would like to
enhance your performance controls we can
click to turbo you can also manually
adjust your thermal controls
oh yeah we have liftoff now baby
the gaming hub will also give you access
to overclocking obviously they're
suggesting this to be for experts only
combined with the adls platform the cryo
chamber is enabling the best
overclocking amongst pre-built systems
so now it's time to play some games and
really test this out i have a bunch of
games already installed i'm going to
turn mac settings on for all of them
because obviously we need to test this
thing and push it to its limits now
fortunately i can't show you gameplay in
this video because it is a sponsored
video and it's really hard to get
clearance from every single publisher to
use the footage in my video so i'll kind
of be giving you guys a play-by-play as
i'm actually playing and tell you what
i'm seeing and what i'm experiencing and
now let's get to it
[Music]
now this is running on the geforce rtx
3090 we have 64 gigs of ram and running
the 12th gen intel core i9 processor so
this is pretty much set to go we are in
full gaming mode now
so let's do it
[Music]
all right so the gameplay looks
incredible but
uh
my
skill level
clearly is
lacking no judgment
also this keyboard is incredible this is
my first time gaming on this keyboard
tyler modded this incredible mechanical
keyboard for me and it is so
good
this is incredible
so like i said i mean our settings are
pretty much completely maxed out i
turned everything that i possibly could
to ultra so
okay hold on a second i gotta i gotta
show this guy what's up or girl
guy girl
dude person dudette whatever who are you
come on now come on now come on but we
might actually win this or we might not
oh come on active camo
we lost okay it's fine it's fine it's
fine
there's more games to be played
[Music]
performance has been awesome and i've
been loving the new cryo chamber i think
this is a really great addition to the
hp omen lineup now my sister is a huge
fan of the hp omen computers she also
has one and when she found out that this
was going to be here today she was over
here so fast to check it out yeah are we
gaming yet i got my mom
[Music]
party
i'll just be inside waiting okay well
thank you again to hp for sponsoring
this video i've been having so much fun
playing games and getting a chance to
really push this thing to its limits
i'll put a link in the description if
you want to get more information about
this new hp omen 45l desktop with the
cryo cooling chamber this thing is so
awesome and i can't wait to play more
games on it again thank you guys for
watching and i will see you in the next
video
oh
[Music]